Stephen Sondheim is complicated and
complex as materialism it's hard enough
to convey emotions through spoken
dialogue but when you add sometimes
music and lyrics to the process how do
you begin to tackle that
well actually I think his music and his
lyrics enhance your ability to
communicate because he's so succinct and
he's so vivid and his language is so
specific and poetic and heightened that
like he shows you the way you need to
sing it and understand it and articulate
it but boy what up you know he does a
lot of the work for you into the woods
some would say Ms Sondheim most poignant
work and it's one that deals with a lot
of issues that are still relevant today
there's there's always going to be a
giant in the world something that the
whole world has to come together to
fight can you talk about that I we've
just been talking a lot about how there
are so many analogies in today's world
with disaster striking and the fear of
the unknown and the fear of the enemy
and how we need to be so brave and
things disasters happen from out of the
blue and how you recover and how you
come together and there's always hope
and there's always love and there's
always people that will help you through
the woods and there's so many of those
messages in this piece and they're
poignant and beautiful and haunting and
frightening and it's such a fantastic
piece and such a privilege to be a part
of it and to talk about all those things
with such a marvelous group but it
helped me enormous Lee on a personal
level
difficult time in my life so I think
it's an amazing piece that's great the
first act is about wish fulfillment the
second act is about how they the effect
that the characters wishes have on
others right can you explain how that
relates to your characters so make sense
we all wish for something yes I wish
that I didn't have such a hard life from
that I had some money I had to I
actually could have some food on the
table I'm very I'm the lowest in there
on the totem pole in this film I have
nothing and we have to wish starving and
then we get everything beyond our
wildest dreams and we become the richest
of all but it's the fight for my child
that's so important to me and my love
for my child who I seem to smack around
the head a hell of a lot but immediately
I kiss him and her frustration and I we
get what we wish for and then it just it
takes a sort of tragic end in our case
but who knows it's funny we kind of
ascend in the Karen Cinderella the
carriage and everybody's it is it's that
happily ever after and no sooner do we
get to the tippy-top and it was shot in
Dover Dover Castle so it's a magnificent
location no sooner do we just all get
there the entire village is happy than
the earthquake happens so it's just just
when you think oh it couldn't be any
happier but man in it that actually is
so like life um I always tell my kids it
goes up and down if you're going through
a hard patch you'll actually then be
going through a smooth patch but you
can't get to the smooth patch without
going through the rough patch so it it's
light and dark and it's up and down and
that's the human experience that's life
and speaking about the castle into the
woods is is sort of unique for a film of
its size and scope in that it was shot
on sound stages and on locations but
using practical sense as opposed to
green screen or CG for once did that
help working in those environments that
that
the performances seen behind you mean
smelt real from day one it did after a
couple of months since well Marcy and
more say yeah rations birds were hung in
the trees who didn't think you didn't
realize that it was all gonna be gone in
a couple of months and it was
astonishing and we would they would
gallop through these woods you know
Chris Pine on his horse and yeah yes
there was very little I mean part from
my Beanstalk which I had to imagine
growing before my very eyes there was
very we could relate to everything you
know and that large destructive forest
that was an enormous set that you know
there were trees and then there were
trees that had been literally destroyed
like like it was a tornado or an
earthquake and we spent a lot of days
shooting that final scene where them the
giant is coming and yeah it was scary
bleak cold on the set oh very sippin
soup like refugees yeah they did feel
incredibly real and what you know the
low we pre recorded some of the music
you could sing it live if you felt it
wasn't the right pace and you know you
didn't feel like you were part of a huge
CGI extravaganza and our performances
meant nothing our performances meant
everything and that was wonderful
yeah that's why you were cast it was
late you really felt you'd earned your
role right that's great
scene you portray more or less an evil
character in the film was that something
that was appealing yeah I mean I you
know I would be a happy to have played
anything in this project I would have
played the coal but anyway sorry ocal
you were on double-bubble she was flying
off to do the goodbye she would like the
hardest-working moment showbiz dude like
famous said you'd fly in for a good one
it's lie back you did a frequent moment
but I actually had have had the good
fortune of being in quite a few Sondheim
either concert versions or workshops
I've never actually been on Broadway
Sondheim musical but I've done like
three of his workshops three concert
versions of different ones so this to me
the combination of reuniting with Rob
Marshall reuniting with Meryl because we
had done Mamma Mia
and then reuniting with Steve and James
Lepine that's just such a trifecta it
was just it was so yummy and then
getting to like know Tracy and work a
little bit with her on the set just
yummy that's great and just quickly
finally Tracy your character can come
across as mean-spirited at times even
though it's obviously it's just being
protective of her son was that a
difficult line to walk between those two
things just smacks her son but you know
she loves him yeah you know day one we
decided that she really it says in the
script no she hits him around the head
and it's like do you do that in just in
movies anymore especially Disney movies
and he thought well when these Grimm's
fairy tales were written you know there
was real violence and fear and I'm you
know but it comes from love and
frustration and poverty and I think she
really shows the love for her son gromek
eventually and I stand up to the Giant
with his behalf and because he means
everything to her so and when I have my
own children and you know you just I
would do anything for my son to I
wouldn't make him sell his cowl they
don't eat cows everybody they're just
like dogs like that cow was just
fantastic she would nudge me to scratch
her ears and I became very fond of
accounts they're not stupid generous
you